hey this is pressure Walker today's
puzzle was sent to me by email and
here's a slightly edited version of the
email I received greetings from Norway I
am a big fan of your videos I got the
following fun quiz at work the other day
and wanted to suggest it for a video I
translated the problem into English
after I spent a long time solving it Tim
is playing a Scrabble like board game
with numbers each piece is either a
digit one to nine or one of the four
operations plus minus multiply or divide
first Tim puts down three pieces forming
a three-digit number like 1 2 3 then he
changes his mind and puts to
multiplication symbols between the
digits like 1 times 2 times 3 the
product of the three digits turns out to
be one-fifth of the original number what
three-digit number did Tim put down
originally thanks Christian you know
Christian must be at a very fun
workplace to have a quiz like this
spread around can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
suppose the original number is ABC since
a times B times C is equal to one-fifth
of ABC and ABC are whole numbers the
original number ABC must be divisible by
five a number divisible by five ends in
either the digit zero or five but since
zero is not a possible value as all
digits are from one to nine this means
we must have five is equal to C next
since a times B times C is equal to ABC
over five we can substitute in C is
equal to five and then write out the
expanded form of the number ABC so we
have five a times B is equal to the
number a B five divided by five and the
number a B five is equal to 100 a plus
ten B plus five we can now divide the
expanded form by five and we get five
times a times B is equal to 20 a plus 2b
plus one we'll use this equation to
proceed to solve for the digits a and B
notice that both 20 a and to be are even
numbers consequently 20 a plus 2 B plus
1 is an odd number
this means 5 a times B is also an odd
number this will only be possible if
both a and B are odd numbers because of
either A or B or an even number that
would make the entire product an even
number so we can limit the search to odd
numbers for a and then solve for B so
suppose a is equal to 1 we substitute
that into our equation and then we saw
that B is equal to seven we can do the
same thing for the other possible values
like a is equal to three we substitute
it in but in this case when we solve for
B we get a value that's not a whole
number and skipping ahead none of the
other cases work and lead to a whole
number value for B the only case that
works is a is equal to 1 and B is equal
to 7
so we have exactly one solution to this
problem a equals 1 B equals 7 and C
equals 5 and indeed 175 divided by 5 is
equal to 35 which equals the product of
the digits 1 times 7 times 5 did you
figure it out thanks for watching this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on map you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions if you like
this video you can also check out my
books which are linked in the video
description or support me on patreon you
can also catch around social media
either at mind your decisions or a
pressure Locker